hello babies how are you listen I just
want to say before we get started with
this episode a lot of you guys have been
really really great who watch man on
fire and tweeted and everything like
that and send me Instagram messages and
all of that snapchats watching the show
before we get started on the show I want
to take a real moment and tell you that
that [ __ ] honestly means the world to me
and thank you for that it's really
really sweet that you guys show your
support and I know a lot of you guys
have watched it a few times I know a lot
of you guys have told your friends and
make your friends watch it and you're
turning your friends on to my comedy and
I just I really appreciate it
and thank you for that and and it's so
before I started the show I wanted to
say that now let's get back to absolute
silliness okay because all that stuff is
very very serious and very true but you
didn't watch it hello hello welcome to
congratulations that podcast this is
jeff of the man sitting in for Chris
D'Elia
I want to say thank you for hey excuse
me don't open em yes I'm back get out of
here
oh okay so long same eret son of a [ __ ]
what's up babies um that's a stupid way
to start this show but you know chillin
dude so okay
it's [ __ ] fourth of July and that's
in America now I know this podcast
people listen to it in Switzerland and
[ __ ] like that and Germany and they
might be like what the hell is fourth of
July but it's where America
the only thing it is is where America
watches fireworks now it's we celebrate
our independence and people making an
excuse to jump in a pool and eat hot
dogs and get drunk and have unprotected
sex probably and then say stuff like bro
it's classic that's what the dudes do
and then the girls go like this a lot
probably yeah
so it's 4th of July we're coming at you
live but you know if you're listening to
this it's not live because it's not snot
streaming it's definitely I'm doing it
live innocent
hey so I've been in LA for two for a
week now and I'm here for another week
and I've got some shows coming up in
Austin and Albuquerque and then I am
also going to be in Montreal we call it
mo clay and also going to be in Utah
look at my web site gonna be in North
Carolina going to be in Australia so
check it out baby's my special came out
this week about a week ago and it was
I'm so happy about it man I was a little
nervous because I was not sure I was a
little nervous about it because it's a
little bit different than what I've been
doing you know I I definitely
myself a lot more and I definitely got
personal in this hour and I'm really
happy I did that because you know trying
to grow here trying to [ __ ] nope I
don't do the same thing over and over
again drives me crazy somebody said
that's the definition of being insane is
doing the same thing over and over and
over again who the [ __ ] was that some
prolific guy you know some genius like
Mark Twain or Albert Einstein or a rod
so yeah and listen man I don't know what
man I I've honestly been chilling in LA
the weather's been [ __ ] beautiful I
got a little bit of a so here's what
happened so I'm not really a
hypochondriac but um I went I I got to I
got to when I was in Florida I got a
burn on my shoulders and now I have like
all these [ __ ] freckles and [ __ ] and
I'm nervous that a lot of them are
cancer so tried to make a an appointment
with the skin doctor just to go over
them go over my shoulders you know I
just wanted to go over my shoulders just
take a 1/2 peek over my shoulders and
kind of be like that one's not cancer
that one's not cancer this one looks
suspect let's get it off you know let's
get off with your shoulder and so I'm
going to go do that and in the meantime
I want to be in the pool on 4th of July
but prade not gone maybe I'll just put
some duct tape over my shoulder and then
just be in the pool and [ __ ] like that
so yeah but dude I know I say this a lot
I don't know why anyone doesn't live
anywhere but la la the weather is
beautiful and a lot of people say the
people suck in LA to those people you
brain-dead you don't know how to you got
serious problems you got issues you have
bad childhood because there's plenty of
people in LA there's millions of people
in LA you can't find six friends you got
walls up ok
hey dude people suck in LA Got News for
you you wanted them peoples well it's
really cool how I've [ __ ] talked 7
lugia since I started doing this show
mmm I try to do that [ __ ] oh but my
voice is back my voice is back in town
my voice is back in town it's better
it's [ __ ] better dude I got it
I can hit high notes you think I can hit
high notes you don't think I can high
notes you want to know if I can you do
the math [ __ ] [ __ ] you do them oh I'm
happy I'm doing new material on stage
and it's the life my mom would always be
like you lived oh you got the life of
Riley don't know what that is but I
think it's good I mean I think it's good
it might not be good it might mean I
[ __ ] I don't know who Riley is I'm an
idiot but yeah I know our podcast
numbers are going up and up and up
because you keep tweeting about it
you guys my friends you guys you're not
technically my friends because don't
know la tía but in a way yeah you treat
me better than mmm friends now that's
real sad but it's also true so that's
why I'm telling you that we're in a cult
okay
now I'm the leader but it's fine it's
cool I'm not gonna be like you know
whipping you guys and making you kill
yourselves or drink poison there'll be a
little bit of manual labor eventually
because I need to relax my job is really
hard and you guys need to like treat me
with some goddamn respect but it's not
I'm not gonna like you know push it you
know like I'm gonna be like build me a
house but there's gonna be like a
thousand of you so it'll be easy it's it
won't be like oh [ __ ] how the do the
four of us do this right it'll be like
oh okay well you know we got some guys
in construction in the cult and we're
all babies so we can figure this [ __ ]
out you know
I was at the Comedy Store and the other
day and by the way was trending on for
LA on Twitter the Comedy Store which is
crazy it's really poppin off man you
gotta go even if I'm not there I know
you if you're a fan of mine still got go
it's a great place support live comedy
also go support the Laugh Factory and go
support the Improv there are three great
clubs in Los Angeles and live comedy is
the [ __ ] if you don't like live comedy
guess what you are you're a chair okay
you don't like live comedy you plant
maybe you're you know what I mean like
you're not human
can we all agree on that go laugh
[ __ ] I understand you know
sometimes you want to go out and you
want to be social and you want to
[ __ ] guys want to get laid and girls
want to get looked at do that after you
go see comedy well I have comedies the
[ __ ] man you got [ __ ] killing
out there on at the Comedy Store you got
Joey Diaz Joe Rogan Anthony Jeselnik you
got Ali Wong you got Sebastian murderers
murderers people who are hard to follow
people who are on stage and now I got to
go out after I'm online now for [ __ ]
sake but yeah so um what happened and
this what happened this week in in the
news you know my buddy told me oh wait
hold on a second what's the [ __ ] I
didn't look it up actually but I heard
about it
the the [ __ ] what was the Oscar the
NBA Oscars or whatever I didn't watch it
I should have [ __ ] watch it Drake
host it no dude I have it
yo I have a question though are you a a
120 page script written by Paul Haggis
and directed by Darren Aronofsky
and does [ __ ] uh who's that guy Sam
Rockwell and Naomi Watts starring you
and are you released by Sony or are you
Kevin Durant I that's the that's the
simple question I have you had the ESPYs
now this is the NBA Oscars or whatever
the [ __ ] they called him you know what
they call it but I've got a sincere
question okay
are you a script by the guy who by the
guy who wrote traffic and are you
directed by [ __ ] David Lynch and do
you star Laurel and bile mmm in Sam
Elliott are you a low-budget movie that
stars Sam Elliott and Lara Flynn Boyle
and are you about an aging alcoholic
that's trying to reconnect with his high
school sweetheart and have him and she's
trying to turn his life around and are
you shot beautifully and do you sweep at
Sundance
or are you Steph Curry because look if
you're the if you're that movie then
have an award you Steph Curry grab a
bass
okay if you're directed by Steven
Spielberg and if you're if you if you're
shocked beautifully then dude then go
get that award but are you are you
[ __ ] are you Kevin Durant put some
shorts on grab a basketball and jump
around
it's so obvious they're just trying to
[ __ ] drive money into the sport
I don't like congratulating the [ __ ]
people who do their jobs
like look if I got nominated for a
[ __ ] a me or an Oscar
best believe I would go I'd throw all
this [ __ ] ideology out the window but
for the meantime look it is a little
uncomfortable though if I honestly if I
did ever if I did ever like having to I
don't know I don't know how I would feel
about it but I just feel weird like how
everyone's patting each other on the
back and [ __ ] like that and you know
playing but especially with basketball
like it it's an it's a sport just just
make the money play the basketball game
for the love of the game right hey for
the love of the game for the love of the
game the love at the game and don't
[ __ ] get in a word for best jump shot
is that what it was was it like best
jump shot her best [ __ ] three-point
Brett best ending two best comeback it
was the one will award is it twenty
minutes in the psych here's the MVP
player I am tough Curry Drake the fact
how much Drake likes basketball is like
hey Drake you rapper or you just gonna
be a [ __ ] commentator are you a color
analysis ya basket per you [ __ ]
rapper my leg will people like switch
careers and [ __ ] like that like do that
kind of [ __ ] like how it's like there
used to be a [ __ ] thing when you'd
get into the New York cabs and you'd
close the door and then the the fair
would start a noble
I'm Paul Sorvino who's an actor who and
he would be like singer dancer actor
writer chef New Yorker and I would be
like chef by oh you're a [ __ ] actor
you're an actor you cook you're an actor
that cooks are you a chef no do you have
a five-star restaurant no to be an actor
singer dancer writer chef New Yorker buy
what doesn't match chef that's like me
saying I'm a [ __ ] architect because I
looked at a house or I told somebody ad
that this was weird you know you cook uh
you know dude here's the other thing too
you work at a restaurant if you're an
actor and you work at a restaurant and
you do a you're a chef don't call
yourself a chef you know nobody's gonna
[ __ ] take you seriously you know
nobody's good does anybody remember that
did anybody in New York remember those
cab rides tweet me if you have actor
singer dancer chef New Yorker that's
what it was actor singer dancer
chef New Yorker stairs were the five
things and when I got in the cab every
time the first time I was like oh went
wall they go all the cab and the guy was
dude one time I was in a cab in New York
and oh man my producer thinks this year
just so funny by the way my producer is
in the other room taking a phone call
for something else he's not with me
right now doing my [ __ ] podcast he's
it he's here in another room taking a
phone call about something else now one
fire him but not gonna ridiculous he
[ __ ] makes a percentage of what the
[ __ ] I do he's in the other room taking
a phone call one fire I'm not gonna cuz
I'm good purse but come on dude it's
free country but dude it's free country
but do your job show up so so [ __ ]
I'm in a cab in New York I think I'm
like nineteen it was when I went to
college for one for eight months at NYU
dropped out
parents were upset for about a few
months starting my career and stand up a
few years later the rest is history
I love how about when people say the
rest is history but it's amazing if
people were to ever say the rest is
history about themselves that would be
amazing I want to be friends with
somebody who would literally look me in
the eye and be like and then I went here
and then I did that and the rest is
history I would take out my dick piss
all over the closest table whatever the
[ __ ] was wherever if we were at a
[ __ ] restaurant right there stand up
take my dick out piss all over the table
and he'd be like what the [ __ ] you do
and I'd be like I don't know what else
to do at this point okay if we were at a
[ __ ] IKEA I'd go over wherever the
table they're selling I piss all over
the table if we were in the forest I'd
be like I got to leave get in my car
wherever I saw a [ __ ] outdoor picnic
table I piss all over the table the rest
is history and they'd be like what are
you do and I'd be like I don't know but
after this the rest is history
so so I'm in a cab and all right so I'm
in a cab and and I'm we get to a stop
light i don't remember where I'm going I
do remember where I was though I was
right I was like on I was in snot Soho
but like I was on like right there like
were hustin is it hustin hustin yeah
houston houston that's it well [ __ ]
idiot dude it's been so long stood in
Houston
it looks like Houston Street right
[ __ ] idiot I'm from I'm from New
Jersey I don't know the [ __ ] streets
in York all right so um and I'm with the
cab driver and he was foreign we either
get a cab driver who's super foreign or
so from New York that like that like he
was born in a cab and like the first
thing they gave him was pizza or [ __ ]
manicotti medic kada manicotti I don't
know anyway like you know why and they
were like is beat the [ __ ] outta here
and they rolled the baby down [ __ ]
down a street in Queens and it hit like
a [ __ ] handbook and it stopped at a
handball court and then that that that's
how New York the guy is like did the
baby came out and the mom goes like this
hey forget about it like in that man
voice she was like forget about it and
threw him a [ __ ] pizza and some
cigarettes and just rolled the baby down
a [ __ ] Street in Queens to a [ __ ] a
handball court and then the baby grew up
and then it was like guess someone be a
[ __ ] gay being there or it's like
some super Indian guy or like you know
somebody from the Middle East and this
was a guy I think he was from the Middle
East and and I the only reason why I'm
not sure is cuz my tread racist I have
no idea so so we're stopped at the
intersection and this young ish lady
walks by I would say I don't know maybe
she's 30 and she's walking by and she's
you know fairly attractive III guess
she's you know I don't really remember I
didn't check her out I just clocked her
like I was like ah there's a lady
crossing the street so that's how you
could imagine that's she was like kind
of fine looking right long dark hair
definitely asian and the cabbie looks at
her and like I can feel him like he's
gonna open his mouth to me I can feel
like he's gonna talk to me and he but
he's and I could see how he's gonna say
check talking about her he's gonna look
at me and talk about her so he kind of
like throws a sentence over his shoulder
to me and he goes and he says about the
girl what a China a racist dude it was
so funny I went I went I yeah I guess
man what a China
he says what a China what a China hey
man at least try to make the sentence
Israel this guy what uh China in a
looking at an asian girl she was not
Chinese I'm sure what a China - we to me
to some yka I loved that he was like
trying to like bro with me though that's
like my favorite when a guy like like
there was one time like when you're at a
coffee shop and this really slamming
chick walks in and like the dudes who
are strangers in the coffee shop or look
at each other and they're like hey
that's an awesome moment as a guy that's
an awesome moment as a guy it's like hey
we're all in this together there's a
beautiful woman I don't know yeah but
you guys you gotta respect the game
that's a [ __ ] great moment so I love
that this guy was doing it but don't say
what a china I mean that's like so funny
I don't know I wonder if like coz you
know you never really know how a foreign
person like feels because they're
foreign or you never know like what
their intentions are right like a
[ __ ] Russian guy could come up to you
and be like I would the rape yeah and
you're like oh well know what what but
he set it up beat you know like what do
you mean like a like a like role-playing
if the girls into it I guess if you have
a safe world safe word I will do rape
right and you're like oh I don't are you
asking me I would put peanut butter in
eyes if you for you and you're like oh
no I don't think so but you know maybe
you know I wonder if afterward she was
like world uh China and then afterwards
she was like I shouldn't have I
shouldn't have said that
or if he was like we brought out wit
brought out he's player I brought out
with an American wits all [ __ ] good I
love the dyrus I've [ __ ] loved at the
moment but it was so funny hey what a
China what uh China you see a [ __ ] New
York girl what a Brooklyn you see a
[ __ ]
a girl from [ __ ] Canada Vlad Manitoba
look if you're choosing a ride-sharing
company to drive for go at the company
that treats you better lift spelled with
a y in case you live under a rock only
lift offers in-app tipping when you
drive for lyft you keep a hundred
percent of the tips 100% drivers have
been paid over 150 million in tip since
the feature was introduced that's a lot
of money
there's Express pay that lets drivers
get paid almost instantly instead of
waiting for weeks you can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips you wanna
make more money drive more it's easy
you're your own boss it's a simple
formula happy drivers mean happy
passengers nine out of ten lift rides
get a perfect five-star rating join the
ride ride-sharing company that believes
in treating its people better go to lift
calm / Congrats today and you can get a
$500 new driver bonus that's lift calm /
Congrats lift calm / Congrats
that's spelled with a Y limited time
only terms apply what a lift do you not
I mean then you could do it you could
drive it you don't even have to take
that cab anymore that I took nobody's
gonna say what a China and lyft for sure
[Music]
so it is time for a segment I like to
call the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week alright and I don't know if
I should give the peoples names out on
Instagram I probably won't because
that's probably I don't want people to
[ __ ] because I like retweeted
something that somebody said negatively
about me today and like people are
posting their home address now hey guys
you don't have to do that okay I kind of
just retweeted it as a joke this so
there's a picture of a guy in his Rolls
Royce SUV which whatever that's fine I
mean I guess it could be douchey but you
know everyone takes pictures in their
car so whatever
he's wearing a tank top uh-oh uh-oh
okay so that just kind of amplified the
douchiness but whatever sometimes people
just wear tank tops okay he's got on
sunglasses which you know it's the
daytime so okay he's got on a watch
which is fine but he's also got on a
bracelet uh-oh uh-oh
okay now we're up in the douche factor a
little bit now he's got gel in his hair
now uh-oh
because I'm checking my phone hold on
let me check the date on my phone okay
so it's mmm July 2017 right yeah okay I
thought for a second my phone so my
phone's not broken right no okay okay so
it's not 1992 okay so uh oh
okay so uh oh all right guys got a tank
top on and he's got a bracelet on and
he's got gel in his hair
but I just took my phone is 2017 so uh
okay now the now look now look now I
look at the caption cuz this guy
now he's flexing his tricep now now now
uh okay now it's just a it's a straight
up uh-oh
now that's fine separately but you got a
you got the Voltron uh oh all right you
got the the he's form in the head and
the hell has jet on the head has gel on
it now now I flustered my sentences
because MBR em right now now let's just
read the caption okay first of all it
begins with what do you call those
doctor thought ellipses uh all right
cuz that means something dramatics come
in when the picture shouldn't be that
dramatic so the sentence should start
with oh but it doesn't it starts with
the ellipses okay now the first word of
the sentence after the ellipses is we
know okay this guy's gonna start telling
us stuff about all of us now uh because
it's a picture of just him flexing with
a tank top on B
Dida sunglasses gel in a rolls-royce
well he's flexing now oh did I slip and
fall because it feels like uh uh am I on
my way to cracking my skull open because
uh oh
now or am I just looking at Instagram
okay here's the sentence after the
ellipses and the sentence that starts
with we we are all a little broken now
oh but the sentence isn't over
which alarms me it's like I'm on my way
down it's like I slipped and I'm at the
point where I know there's no way I can
regain my balance and I'm thinking oh
[ __ ] so the uh-oh is kind of turning to
how do I live past this moment I need to
get through it
now you're during its we're in the
sentence here we're already in we're
involved we are all a little broken but
the last time I checked broken crayons
still color the same it's not over
there's a space now I know what you're
thinking now right now you're at the
point where you feel the ground you feel
it your your your your hitting the
ground and the only thing you're trying
to do is guard make sure your head
doesn't hit the [ __ ] sidewalk right
you're like this is gonna be [ __ ] up
I'm gonna get scrapes and my my arms
gonna hurt but I [ __ ] hope my head is
fine now here's what the rest of the
post is he says what consumes your mind
controls your life then he puts a
[ __ ] circular star emoji I'd never
even seen that one
feed your focus and starve your
distractions now plain and simple oh
because this is the moment where you
slipped and fell
you hit your body and you thought your
head was going to be okay but what
happened was your head hit a higher part
of the concrete and you didn't know it
was there like you hit the curb and your
head is going to be so bruised and you
pissed and [ __ ] yourself because of it
uh-oh
hey guy back up a second go tunc get
sleeves stop flexing take off the
sunglasses mess your hair up get a new
car take off your bracelet and stop
typing on Instagram after you post a
picture of it all oh be safer we don't
need to be in the [ __ ] territory and
the guys person is lips by good gunk
dude excuse me back up hey dude you know
what man
how about this I get in your car stay in
your car now let me close the door on
you okay donk see you later bye bye I'm
watching him go I'm watching him drive
down Sweetzer and then there's people
commenting with a [ __ ] bicep emojis
and the 100 emojis can we stop posting
the 100 emoji stood on [ __ ]
[ __ ] I want an emoji of a guy
that has his [ __ ] hand over his face
and his eyes wide and and that's the om
oj I want you to find these [ __ ] post
I want you to find this post I'm not
saying the guy's name cuz I don't need
the [ __ ] but just post up just uh-oh
there's right out on these [ __ ]
okay this is the that was the segment
most [ __ ] up Instagram post all week
and I'm gonna keep doing these because
these guys dude Duk dong man yo CUDA
get out of here sniff dude it's free
conch you post whatever you want but you
kuda these people actually they don't
have jobs and [ __ ] well maybe they don't
but like you people that you're gonna go
to work you're gonna see these
[ __ ] so that's the segment
we're gonna do and you know if you find
them tag me you know could be a guy or a
girl and that'll be your submission just
tag me on these [ __ ] on these most
[ __ ] up Instagram posts all week I
because they make me laugh in all
honesty I just want to do [ __ ] that I
want to do and that's what's uh-huh up
dude I'm gonna sing more I'm gonna sing
more in my life because because I got my
voice back and I still think about it
and it's so awesome when the [ __ ]
post mates guy comes I'm just giving
thanks for the food dude there's a guy
on post mates that deliver my food the
other day and he had he looked like a
[ __ ] straight-up vampire
he had like but like the handsome one
like a cool one not like the table the
one you know but like the [ __ ] yet
bleached blond hair and it was super tan
and looked like I might [ __ ] him if I
got drunk or something dude do you guys
watch this isn't a proper promo do you
guys watch this strain on FX I I watched
the first two episodes and I'm [ __ ]
into that show I love that actor the
[ __ ] main actor and I like it a lot
but that's two episodes and I don't know
if it gets worse or better but I know it
has like two or three seasons I think so
I'm happy about that I just like all
these shows man they're just hard to
watch even if they're really [ __ ]
good it's like I don't want to be that
[ __ ] uh I need it to be a little bit
like fun you know what I mean like Game
of Thrones I saw four episodes and I
know everyone's like well you gotta wait
and wait it out it's like you
yeah and I'm not saying it's not a good
show it's a great show but like I don't
want to have to be like so dramatic
myself while watching it a show you know
like like 24 to me was a great show
because it was like so ridiculous but
also like thrilling but like I got a
watch [ __ ] you know I didn't watch it
and I want to see it and I'm sure it's
[ __ ] amazing but I got what's the
leftovers like I got to watch them
they're gonna be crying and [ __ ] what
did we do
like that's every show now what did we
do that's every show good gunk I want
lager I want I love I love the show
though they're great shows I am a
hundred percent now I want to be in
those shows I want to be in a show where
I would somebody would be like gunk to
me but like you know give me a [ __ ]
blood sucker or some [ __ ] give me a guy
with a fucked-up face that's like a
demon I'm all in that show man uh yeah I
don't know but anyway the show's [ __ ]
cool two episodes in I don't know but
like I even started like Battlestar
Galactica and it's just like you know I
love the show but it's like after six
episodes I'm like okay it's so dramatic
same thing with madmen greatest show
ever uh but like I get tired watching it
because it's like so dramatic I don't
know that I just burn [ __ ] 75 bridges
I'm telling you those are the shows I
want to be in hire me let me be in those
[ __ ] shows where I get to like
[ __ ] cry and but be like shirtless
but not fit you know what I mean but
like so where they were like oh that's
odd that he's sitting like that because
it makes his belly come out Oh
his [ __ ] cat a khaki or like slacks I
want to do a show I wear slacks five for
club understands that your time is
extremely valuable you guys heard about
five for why waste your time at the mall
or wandering around in these stores
they've been Lee the leading menswear
brand for over 15 years and you can
trust them with your wardrobe I do it
each month they send you a curated box
of to three items two to three items
that are hand-picked to match the
current season on your style so if
you're not stylish let them do it
they've been have a men with over with
fashion for over 15 years and shipped to
over 100,000 men every month I'm one of
them
hi I'm one of them they know what
they're doing if you don't that's okay
now I know what I'm doing but I still
let them do it and I wear some of their
shirts they're very cool five for club
will help you build your wardrobe one
month at a time you get $120 worth Tawes
worth of clothes for just $60 a month
$60 a month your paws cancel anytime
there's no commitments as a 5-4 Club
member you'll receive up to 50% off
items on their online shop and access to
exclusive Members Only items free
shipping and size exchanges go to five
for club calm right now and enter promo
code Congrats and they'll give you 50%
off your first month's package plus a
free pair of sunglasses
what and that doesn't cost $14,000 no
that's 50% off your first package at 5-4
Club spelled fi ve fo you are club.com
promo code Congrats 5-4 Club comm promo
code Congrats what it doesn't cost 14
million dollars no it costs what it
costs cz Mark Wahlberg uses it
I like mark Mark Wahlberg Mark Wahlberg
would be like yeah I use 5 folder I use
5 4 I go to find 4 club comm all the
time I put it on the shirts in the pants
all the time well the time I put them on
so do it
MNH Erb ox we all want to eat better but
when it comes to snacks sometimes it
feels like
whole world is delicious and a billion
calories versus boring and tasteless
doesn't have to be that way up your
snack game with nature but you've been
looking up your snack game I have I walk
around I'm like how do I up my snack
game naturebox
has over a hundred snacks that taste
good and are actually better for you all
snacks are made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
color colors flavors or sweeteners so
you can feel good about what you're
eating the salt-and-vinegar veggie chips
are good they're awesome actually aged
cheddar lentil oops you kidding me all
those words I like and they're all in
the same thing I love those aged aged
cheddar dude if you're eating regular
cheddar go to lunch get out of here eat
an aged cheddar I trust you get your new
snack obsession on at naturebox it's so
simple go to naturebox calm and nature
box will deliver them right to your door
like you're a king there's no risk
either you do it you don't like to snack
don't eat it
you don't like to snack don't eat it
they'll replace it for free you'll save
even more if you do it now nature box is
offering Congrats fans 3 free snacks
with your first order
when you go to nature box calm Congrats
it's nature box calm for 3 free snacks
with your first order nature box calm
you don't know how to spell it go school
dude imagine sitting down this isn't
even part of anything but I met as part
of the podcast now imagine imagine
sitting down and eating regular cheddar
and knowing there's aged cheddar out
there and you're skipping it the [ __ ] is
wrong with you dude if you have
cheddar you better [ __ ] put it
somewhere and wait years before you eat
it so then it's aged cheddar okay act
like you've been somewhere [ __ ] put
your cheddar down and go on vacation
come back eat the cheddar take one of
those long [ __ ] holiday trips that
Australians always take hey Australians
why is your vacation always four months
long don't you have a job don't you have
family that's gonna miss you don't you
have a girlfriend
Australians are always like going on all
that I play back in 2030 where are you
going I don't know
I've got one-way ticket did if you go on
a vacation you have a goal when you take
and you have a one-way ticket
you are either somebody who's got severe
problems and now I'm mark my words
you're either somebody who's got so many
problems like you were touched for sure
as a young boy or girl sorry but you
were probably or now I mean this or you
are absolutely 100% one of the top ten
most well-adjusted people in the world
there is no in-between there's no
in-between either trying to find
yourself or you know who you are and
you're going to live life there's no
[ __ ] in-between dude why do people
always have to go somewhere else to find
themselves hey you're right there you're
in you don't go to Africa you're where
you are I just wanted to go to you know
I wanted to go to Japan to find myself
ah really all your things are where you
are you know dude I feel like you know
we just we had to go dude we had to go
to Prague you know just kind of [ __ ]
let loose and just see who we are really
you know get out of our comfort zone and
find ourselves you know where you are in
your goddamn comfort zone that's where
you are found yeah hey man
found you you know where you are in your
clothes don't go to Prague found you
you're going to Australia to find
yourself don't you where you are Hague
Australian you're going in New York to
find yourself don't found ya you didn't
Sydney but I need to hold on back up
gunk uh you know people are so lost
people are so [ __ ] lost and I guess
I'm lost too but I'm not going anywhere
to find myself you know where I am my
house in your condo swear you are go
look in the bedroom maybe you're in
there you don't need to go to Zimbabwe
loving it dude love in it uh-huh
I love it I love it
let's look at these [ __ ] gaming the
system's babies let's see who gamed the
system today man
god I love how I was gonna call it the
congratulations Congrats pot what's the
tweet what's the thing congratulations
pod good thing my producer sounds like
he's [ __ ] is crying but
congratulations pod is the Sun fairy
advocacy does have a lack of funding
we're not getting him on either okay all
right here we go oh wow this is a good
one dude Nick Goodwin came through with
this now what he didn't come through
with was this handle because his handle
is at underscore hey look man you start
your handle with an underscore pick
something else
all right you know like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you especially if it's this
at underscore Buena Victoria hey man
somebody got Buena Victoria
change it be Nick Goodwin be underscore
Nick Goodwin for [ __ ] sake
this guy underscore Buena Victoria by
change it back up the gunk you gota
but this is a great question I love it
hey Chris hey a crystal eeeh how do you
feel about people calling their friends
their team yeah man dude you're not Hey
Dude are you on the Rancho Cucamonga
quakes or are you Sarah
all right hey I hate are you on the
[ __ ] Rancho Cucamonga quakes or do
you just know a guy named Ken and a guy
named Jacob don't call your friend your
team do it you're just people put on a
mick go out and [ __ ] throw a ball
around then you're a team you just out
at a bar no here we go Madoff reduced ax
ax Scott Schwartz 34 now I would tell
you to change it but that's something
you probably learned on the podcast
considering you're tweeting at the
podcast and Madoff released our metaphor
jeast I don't know how it's pronounced
cuz not true Italian I'm just an
American that has some background
Italian in me so you twice last year
hashtag real baby hashtag real baby
hashtag real baby did I say real baby
maybe I must have and loved the LL Cool
J bit just wondering why it didn't make
man on fire and that's a good question
you know sometimes these bits I like
them too
thank you by the way that's very sweet
the bit it's funny to me yeah I'd it's a
bit about LL Cool J that I do when I met
LL Cool J and loved LL Cool J and um I
just I don't know sometimes these bits
just don't do it didn't it didn't
honestly didn't fit into the theme of
what I was talking about the whole theme
of man on fire was we're not special and
it didn't it didn't fit in it maybe I'll
save it for something else sometimes I
bring these bits back and maybe well
I don't I don't know Jessie Benbrook at
Jessie benbrook how do you feel about a
guy with a lift kit on his truck I've
talked about this already actually you
got a truck and you put all sorts of
[ __ ] on it get a car get a car
how about a truck with the [ __ ]
flatbed the cover on it get a car uh
this guy went this guy this guy's name
is Ralph Nader on his thing and his at
the handle is at Chris D'Elia num 1 so
I'm assuming the number 1 unless she's
saying I don't have feelings ah this guy
went [ __ ] ham Jesus Christ
this guy I'm just gonna read all of his
questions what do you think about people
who use social media to hook up with
girls here's another one what do you
think about the airplane bathrooms what
are your top 5 favorite shoes be
specific I like how this guy's giving me
[ __ ] if you're gonna do it be
specific [ __ ] what do you think
about Kylie Jenner dating only black
eyes what do you think about frats and
college life Jesus Christ this case
there's so many of them this guy did
give me a [ __ ] me kill or whatever dude
have a people who actually play [ __ ]
marry kill that's not fun hey dude [ __ ]
marry kill this person that person this
person and then somebody goes oooh ok
that's a good one well definitely
definitely kill yada yada no that's dumb
Yokota you're asked to look good oh my
god dude
this person said me a picture at L ll at
DJ underscore Leslie 20 changed the
whole thing change both you're gonna
love this and it's a picture I'm gonna
tweet this picture cuz this is
unbelievable I'll actually I'll retweet
it or some [ __ ]
I'm gonna favorite at night right now
you're I mean this pic this [ __ ]
goddamn it's a [ __ ] tank top with
that's nice
on green it says really large letters
beasts and then under it it has like an
iPhone thing that says slide to unlock
whoa dude and it looks like they're
selling them and yeah they're definitely
selling them and there's a bunch of them
left dude if somebody had that I'd
[ __ ] press really hard on their chest
and really try to slide to unlock it and
when they said hey man what the [ __ ] you
do and I said oh dude sorry man I was
just trying to unlock the beast in you
now growl now go scratch people
unbelievable
saving it I'm gonna tweet it wow you're
right dude usually sometimes people are
wrong about this you're gonna love this
but I really like that amazing great
find
DJ underscore Leslie 20 change it Wow oh
let's go back to
my five favorite shoes be specific hey
brother foods here if you want to go
grab it if you don't want fire what was
I saying oh five top five favorite shoes
that's a cool one I'm a I'm a sneaker
head okay I'm not gonna be that specific
well because people don't give a [ __ ]
about it but here's the ones I like I
like the [ __ ] I like I love I love
Jordan ones I've always loved the Jordan
ones the first ones that they came out
with you know I like the Royals I like
the black and red
I love nmds now they're great the
enemies are awesome I love the first
original ones with the blue and red
plugs that are black the black shoes
that are blue and red and the white ones
that are blue and with the blue and red
plugs but I also like all the different
ones I like I like I probably would say
I like the Jordan threes fours and fives
not the 5s they're too big
they're too bulky but the threes and
fours I mean I like the fires I have
some I got the fives what do you call
them I [ __ ] forget what they're
called the green ones with the gold
tongue dissuade ones those are [ __ ]
awesome those premium ones I love those
premium fives they came with the black
ones and they're [ __ ] awesome so yeah
oh by the way the artwork that
everybody's been sending me from a know
far has been very cool
I've been reposting a lot of those on my
Instagram and I did that for the past
week and I really think that that's cool
it's it's definitely nice that you guys
do that and you guys are babies you know
and that's great mmhmm yeah
all right well look I I don't see any
more questions here that are
worth the answer I mean I'm not seeing
him all obviously there so many of them
but yeah all right
yeah so that's it thanks United again a
jet catches fire Denver Airport we were
like tweet about this but I didn't know
if anyone got hurt so I don't want to
make fun of it if they got hurt you know
yeah all right cool
well that's that you guys are awesome
dude go to my website to go to my
website to look at the what do you call
it
tours I got going on let me let me just
[ __ ] read some of these off here
because I know some of you aren't gonna
do it Austin Texas Albuquerque New
Mexico Montreal Canada Nashville
Tennessee Nashville Tennessee Salt Lake
Utah Phoenix Arizona Tempe Arizona
Spokane Washington Charlotte North
Carolina
Irvine California and Australia although
that's not up on my website yet will you
email my people about that yeah
otherwise I mean one fire but you don't
want that right I mean well I think I
probably did email a long time ago so
don't one fire but anyway
yeah well you do sometimes [ __ ] stuff
like that up but you don't but you do
okay agree disagree anyway so that's
what's up you guys
thank you for watching man on fire and
if you haven't watched a man on fire yet
watch it the [ __ ] you don't you can
watch it whenever it's streaming on
Netflix but do it
and also there's merch up on Chris
D'Elia calm in the store tag
we got congratulations you can support
the podcast we got congratulations
t-shirts we got shirts of that that it
show you're a fan of my comedy all that
[ __ ]
when I see people wearing that to my
shows it's [ __ ] so sweet man do we
have the new merch up yet
no okay we're getting new merch up to
merchandise I don't like when people say
merch don't like it
merchandise it's easy enough to say it
but you succumb to what the [ __ ] the
world happened and make make sure to
come to sometimes you know I don't want
to be left out don't wanna be left out
but by the way somebody was talking to
me about how like hey you say you don't
like to abbreviate words but all that's
all you do is abbreviate words no don't
abbreviate words I don't do that
stiff language stiff language all right
stiff language it's good gunk an
abbreviation not stiff Lanie
so yeah so do all that if you would rate
and review the show download it stitch
or Google Play it's also on pornhub
notes on on for now but yeah so rate
review it on iTunes be a big help
watching the special on Netflix and what
some special on Netflix and you guys
thank you very much my babies this is
Chris D'Elia signing off for another
week of congratulations podcast remember
guys what a China
[Music]